[Music]
espd is stands for
ethnopharmacologic
search for psychoactive drugs
and in 1967 the national institute of
mental health sponsored
a conference in san francisco by that
name and it was a closed conference
the only thing the taxpayers ever got
out of it was this book that they
published the proceedings of the
conference well somehow or other
that came on to my radar at the age of
18
and
the next year the year after the
conference was done it was somehow i got
it
and it opened up the world for me of
ethnopharmacology well the government
staged this conference published this
book they were supposed to have
follow-up
events every 10 years or so to keep
abreast of what was going on in the
field
well that never happened
the
the war on drugs came along they
they were embarrassed basically they'd
never done anything even though you
could order it from the us government
printing office for many years well so i
always wanted to stage a follow-up and
50 years went by
circumstances never allowed that to
happen but in 2017 everything came
together
i had funding i had a place i had people
to help me organize it
and you know i want to give a shout out
to them because
it wasn't me that did it i had a lot of
help some of them
and so we did this this conference in
2017 we did espd 50. this commemorative
50th anniversary conference
and
we uh
we published the original
67 volume together with the 2017 volume
as a box set we put the videos on
the videos are still up there people can
watch them
and so now it's been five years so we
decided to do a five-year follow-up
god knows if i'll be here in 10 years so
you know we decided to do a five-year
follow-up and that's what espd50
is the five year from the 2017
conference or the 55th year of the first
conference
and
that's the origin that's the whole idea
of it the 2017 conference was pretty
much focused on ethnopharmacology and
sort of the unexplored
dark corners or you know fringes of
ethnopharmacology in other words the
ideas that search for psychoactive drugs
it's a quest
we're doing that this year we have some
really interesting topics we have for
example one
person that's presenting on
psychedelics found in sponges and you
know marine sponges and that sort of
thing
but we've also got a couple forums we
have three forums that don't really fit
into this pattern one of them
is
a forum on coca
and they need to destigmatize coca so
we've got
coke is a wonderful medicine as coca not
as cocaine is horrible cocaine is a
horrible drug but coca
is beneficial and coca
is
just at the center of andean traditions
and medicine and all that
and potentially could be as a
nutraceutical as an herbal medicine it
could be very beneficial and
there are all sorts of aspects because
you give the people who grow it who
formerly were basically just told
by the cartels okay you work for us now
if you don't produce it we'll just kill
you
but give those
families mostly economic benefits and
bring coca back as a as a respected
medicine so we've got wade davis
participating in this we've got andy
weil they're both of them long time
advocates of of coca as a medicine
and a food actually which it also is
it's very nutritionally beneficial
i want to take a second just to
get into
some of the logistics of espd55 as a
sidebar i'll just say the box set of
books for espd50 you can find online you
can find them on amazon they're
beautifully done
i have them on my bookshelf absolutely
a joy to read
for espd55 people can find that at
espd55.com i'll put that in the show
notes and people can
either attend in person in the uk may
23rd to 26th this is 2022 or they can
attend online are those the the two
primary options that are available for
folks
yes that's right and less less and less
in person because because it's rapidly
filling up basically the in person but
we intend to live stream it and when we
did the
50 we had at times we had 75 000 people
participating we hope to meet or exceed
that benchmark this time and uh
there will be another book there'll be
another there'll be a book that comes
out of it only one this time but it'll
be
also high quality and it will match the
[Music]
you know the design and everything to
the previous one so it'll look good on
your shelf and the person that just that
provided the art that
amazing lovely watercolors that were
incorporated into the design she
is there's a link to her website she's
selling
prints essentially print prints uh
print sets of about i think
about a hundred of her illustrations
that people can order
if they wish and they're beautiful so
so dennis one thing i'd like to do to to
sell this event if it's okay with you
and we can cut this out if it ends up
being more than you'd like to reveal but
i just want to give some teasers for
folks i'm not going to give away too
much
or i won't give a lot of the specifics
but let me just give some other samples
of sessions is that okay with you dennis
sure
okay so there's a session on kratom a
lot of people have questions about
kratom metro john espiciosa if i'm
pronouncing that correctly mr giannine
fascinating fascinating plant
i'm going to put this in a little
gingerbread trail so i'm not going to
fill in all the gaps but a road map for
sustainable development of ayahuasca
production in the amazon lowlands
great interest to me
yes psychedelic fauna so to be
distinguished from flora i'll just put
that
i'll leave that alone i won't go into
that too much here's another
history of psychoactive plants and fungi
in chinese medicine something you do not
hear in
at least much that i have at all in
mainstream conversations
you mentioned marine sponges
yield enhancing lessons from silicon
which is what psilocybin is but quickly
metabolized into
in the human body i guess that's
probably what
maybe first pass metabolism through the
liver
we've got hunting medicines among the
matsi genka the harpy's gift to the
jaguars curse
great title
watchuma the sort of phytochemical
profiling of wachuma some people might
know that as san pedro cactus
also very interesting to me personally
from a
from a
conservation and sustainability
perspective because it grows so much
faster than say peyote
which is endangered very very endangered
added an anthro
so i'm gonna leave that alone but if
people have never heard that word a it's
a lot of syllables b
fascinating history
i mean there is contemporary use but
that's kind of beyond the scope of of
what we're talking about right this
second
establishing collections of sacred
psychoactive medicinal plants at
wasiwaska that's in floripa
you have some amazing speakers i can
just say not as as the leading expert in
this field but as someone who is
certainly an avid consumer and spectator
tourist
do read a lot you have an outstanding
roster of speakers here's one you don't
see every day chemically induced
otherworldly experiences of zoroastrians
in iran i mean
yes please would love to be part of that
incredible i mean where else are you
going to find that answer is probably
nowhere
and it just goes on and on and on so
i'll leave it at that there i i didn't
even i i didn't even cover
50 of it so there's there's a lot here
and there's there are many documentaries
you have people who are very well known
we didn't get into his resume at all but
wade davis
certainly
yeah i mean the whole idea
of the espd conferences is that
they're out of the box in a certain way
it's not just the same stuff i mean i'm
happy that there are all these
virtual uh meetings about the
therapeutic uses of uh psilocybin and
in ptsd and
addiction i mean that's important stuff
but there's a lot of duplication in some
of these things we want to we want to
kind of stake out an area and look into
the obscure
corners but still
important and
and kind of highlight the
the work that remains to be done for
example the wachuma project is very
interesting
and and i can claim a little bit of
credit for it the person that's going to
present there primarily
is
a student of wave davises actually in at
ubc she's in the phd program and then
her partner and colleague a
peruvian gentleman
joseph
i forget his last name sorry but they've
collaborated on this
and
when i
was asked to be on laurel uh laurel's
laurel sugden is her name asked to be on
her committee i
asked them if they asked her if she was
interested in in the chemistry side of
this the ethnopharmacology side of it
not just the ethnography
and she
indicated that she was that this was
interesting to her
so we
we hooked up with a
investigator at the albany college of
pharmacy who's developed an innovative
way
to
non-invasive way to sample plants and
and create you know do uh like
phytochemical fingerprints essentially a
quick way to look at the variation in
the different varieties and species of
this cactus and then using mass
spectrometry and other fancy tools
actually do a like a phytochemical
fingerprint of these different
varieties and so on so it's going to be
a very interesting
presentation that combines ethnography
chemistry and pharmacology
yeah and there's others like that
michael is going to talk about his work
with the
with the cultural key cell species
michael coe
and uh
and then as you mentioned the people
from icers we've got two two people from
isis that are talking
about the whole issues related to
the
unintended consequences of ayahuasca
tourism basically yeah
depletion of the species and all of that
and
how do we address that so
i think it's going to be a stimulating
conference
you